if there's one thing the hellraiser
franchise has taught us it's that you
should never mess with puzzle boxes as
horror fans already know the lament
configuration is the staple element of
the hellraiser movies and one of the
most iconic and enduring props from the
series acting as a bridge between our
world and that of the cenobytes now that
hulu's hellraiser reboot is finally here
the lament configuration is front and
center once again but this time it's
here in a wildly different shape the
newest hellraiser marks the 11th
installment in the franchise although
several movies in the series chose the
direct to video route understandably
fans have been freaking out over the
newest trailer for hulu's hellraiser
reimagining but many are wondering about
the lament configuration's strange shape
at the opening of the trailer
particularly since it then progresses to
become the cube we recognize from past
films considering the breadth of the
hellraiser franchise the lore and
history surrounding the lament
configuration is fairly robust the most
important feature of this demonic puzzle
box is that once an individual solves it
it creates a pathway between this world
and a dimension of untold pain and
madness the inhabitants of this evil
realm are usually referred to as
cenobytes each of them unique and frozen
in various states of ecstatic physical
torture but what each cenobite has in
common is that they're twisted into a
form of cruel mockery that represents a
person's mortal failings in some way and
above all don't open the box he needs
you to open the box but don't throughout
the series the lament configuration
usually takes the form of an
inconspicuous yet mysterious puzzle box
that often becomes an obsession for the
humans that gaze upon it however the
shape of this mystical object is not
fixed often once a lament configuration
is solved the box has a tendency to
unfurl quickly changing size and
appearance in a display of mechanical
perfection according to hellraiser lore
the lament configuration seen in the
movies thus far was originally created
in the 1700s by a french toymaker at the
behest of a noble person who was
obsessed with magic the noble thought
this puzzle box would grant him untold
powers with the ability to summon
cenobites for his own purposes however
it never works that way and summoning
these entities tends to result in
torture and death it's also important to
note that this is not the first nor only
lament configuration in fact in one of
the prior hellraiser movies there are
several on display not only is there
more than one lament configuration but
the design itself can be reversed to
trap the cenobites this was highlighted
in hellraiser bloodline where an entire
space station acts as an inverted lament
configuration that can trap and bind the
demons according to scary studies
original pinhead actor doug bradley once
explained you have to become aware of
the lament configurations and then you
have to find one and then solve the
puzzle it's not just the physical act of
opening the box it's the motivation
behind it
time to play another game
in essence there is indeed more than one
box and those boxes aren't necessarily
beholden to one specific shape and size
as a result it's perhaps not that
surprising that the lament configuration
has such a different shape in the first
moments of hulu's hellraiser trailer
perhaps this isn't the same lament
configuration previously featured
throughout the franchise or it could be
a different configuration of the puzzle
box entirely the rectangular form could
also represent an unopened state of the
configuration the trailer does mention
that there are six different
configurations to that one specific
puzzle box meanwhile director david
bruckner cautioned fans not to try to
place the new movie too directly into
existing hellraiser continuity telling
gizmodo i wouldn't say it's strict canon
again we let our imaginations run with
this my suggestion to fans is to go into
it not thinking exactly where it's
fitting in the history of the series and
to just experience the film regardless
lament configurations always result in
the same thing and that's suffering pain
and body horror truthfully when you have
a puzzle box that acts as a portal to a
demonic realm it probably isn't heavily
restricted by design or shape but the
outcome remains the same
[Music]
you